on this episode I talk about selling
merchandise how the price sponsorship of
your show and Tim Ferriss stops by you
ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
oh sure sorry guys
I like you know what I like it I think I
look very fresh the other thing the
other thing that I like is through that
whole beard experiment I realized that
you can keep your facial hair at the
same exact size all the time if you want
to so I think I'm gonna buy a trimmer
and I this is two days I think it's like
five or six days that I like the length
and I may have a permanent 5 o'clock
shadow for like yeah exactly he rocks it
it's so funny I don't know why I didn't
recognize that you're able to do that
I literally just thought people's facial
hair just stopped and mine just kept
going and others just kept going like it
was it's really like a very basic thing
that I just didn't understand happened
in the world yeah anyway that's quite
sad 91 hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and you're watching episode
91 of the askgaryvee show you may also
be listening to it little rusty from not
doing a show for six or seven days so I
said watched instead of this is 91 a
tremendous number a number of my
favorite New York Jack Sheldon
Richardson the NFL Draft is on Thursday
I'm filming recording this on a Tuesday
so if you're watching it right now or
tonight or tomorrow I want you to know
that I am going to Chicago for the NFL
Draft and I fully intend to be the face
of the New York Jets pick because I
don't expect as many jet fans in Chicago
as normally in New York I will be
cozying up to the cameraman both on the
NFL Network and espn.com and I'm very
confident that the Jets will select XYZ
player they will compan two fans and it
will be me and AJ saying yay or boo so
I'm excited for that look for that let's
get in to the show India Aaron ass
actually before we get into the show I
missed not doing the show for six or
seven days miss everybody Big Ups to
everyone a meerkat and now India let's
get into the show
Aaron ass wait I'm just kidding okay
Aaron ass everyone visiting my site will
be there for custom music should I delay
them with content Aaron this is a very
interesting question for a very specific
reason if you're watching a meerkat I
kind of had a talk to India four or five
times on this question and really fully
get it and then I realized
aha that's why I don't get it because of
the way you position the question my
friend if you notice to the sentence
structure something I never understood
because I have no grammar skills you say
delay them with content that in itself
is the problem it's the energy that you
approach this question with which is
that you're saying to yourself do I put
out content that isn't my best interest
instead of theirs hence the word delay
and the way I always talk about it is
putting out content that actually brings
value to people and so when I say a pop
up you know when I say don't stop them
from going to what they want to that's a
pop-up ad that's not bringing them any
value if you put out content that isn't
the music but maybe is the behind the
scenes of you're a mixing the music
getting the music your thoughts on the
music if you bring them other value well
then you're bringing value I mean people
watch a show to get to the answers do
they enjoy the banter that I have before
when me and you make that cut we get
into the show or my Jets thing or
whatever you know I think there's a
certain subset that does enjoy that and
that's why I've been able to pull off
video show after video show cuz I'm
trying to make it interesting with other
things besides the hardcore content some
people think that's too much they don't
like and then they won't be there but at
the end of the day the fact that you say
they'll lay them with content means that
the energy and the seed of how you're
approaching it is wrong what you need to
do is make that value-added content make
that part of the overall experience make
that the reason they come and I think
you know I think that that is something
that people really misunderstood I think
the Mets have a much better stadium than
the Yankees because of all the added
venues and the nuances and the ambience
of their stadium I'm there for the
ballgame people are there for the
ballgame but there's always an added
value of why you're there it may be a
dartboard in a bar is the dartboard
there to stop them from drinking another
mirror no it adds so let's add
vaynernation let's not subtract
it's interesting the way Aston he's
already against it it's already not for
them it needs to be for them back
hey Gary Christophe here with scalar
code calm
how would you price sponsorships for an
episode of a show like askgaryvee would
you go by the number of views by the
number of sales they get what do you
think thanks Gary yes I think that there
is a very simple answer to this my big
belief when you're selling sponsorship
to something new is you ask for as much
as possible I'm not kidding you don't
know what your ceiling is if you go by
see PM's and views you're really a tough
spot because views and and impressions
have been commoditized to such a level
that you'll never hit enough scale most
people are gonna make four dollars on
their show sponsorship if they go that
route it's the Association notice I
don't run ads or sell sponsorship on the
show and if I did I would expect
substantial Bank because not only it's
not about the 20 30 40 50 thousand
YouTube and 15 60 70 80 thousand
Facebook impressions and awareness and
all that nature it's about the brand
association you know I'm endorsing it by
accepting it cuz I've never done it
before and so there's an extra value on
that and so I think the thing that you
really need to think about is is if it's
a small business startup you need to
negotiate there needs to be just a price
and you start high if it's a media
buying agencies you're already in
trouble because they're looking to buy
scale and they're really looking to
commoditize your traffic and that is not
gonna make sense for 99.9% of the people
listening and watching this show and so
my advice is to price Adhan and then the
second part of your question about the
conversion of sales you don't want to be
in direct response conversion based
business either what you want to be is
in the brand association pricing right
you know there you can't put a price on
a small business oriented solution being
a sponsor of this show because they're
getting to entrepreneurs and executives
through this channel and there's more
depth and width and so I would price it
as high as humanly possible
and let it land to where the market
actually says I think one of the big
myths
that a lot of my friends watch the show
and a lot of people that negotiate in
general they don't price accordingly
because they ask for what they want and
usually you should at least double or
triple what you want to leave room for
the negotiation or by not you know a lot
of times you're limiting your upside by
brot not recognizing that you've missed
or underpriced your value problem a
bunch of deck heads wants to know if
you're selling merch like t-shirts how
would you go about doing it
well that kids I mean this is a very
good question I like this question I
don't want to beat a dead horse but I
would say Facebook dark posts is
incredibly interesting the targeting
capabilities of what's going on in that
platform are incredible I think
Pinterest and promoted pins is another
place that I would spend a ton of my
time and energy and I would say
traditional digital even though
something I like to pick on I think
SEM Google AdWords and I think banner
retargeting you know people landing on
your site you pixel in them and cooking
them from the traffic that you got from
the other places and then retargeting
them on banner and things that nature
have all been proven t-shirt hoodie
you know hat selling I think Facebook
dark posts though are incredible the
fact that you can target people that are
fans of P Spring or busted tees or all
these kind of you know Threadless
Jackthreads all these places were though
those kind of things are soul Johnny
Cupcakes in fact you can target to that
level just incredible I mean like I mean
you know it's a it's really a funny
thing to do this show because I keep
pounding this narrative and so many of
you continue not to do it but a couple
of you are starting to smell me saying
hey thank you for this because this is
what's happened so that makes me happy
it makes me continue to want to spew the
best advice possible and to me 50% of my
money would be allocated to Facebook
dark posts with the other 50% allocated
to things I just told you about by the
way it's tough on this whole episode I
don't you know I haven't you know I
don't watch my stuff I don't know what
you guys have been doing from an editing
standpoint but even this part right now
in color when it's the show in black and
white when it's not the part where I
yield Zach I like that part this right
now got it
are talking got it we've been doing it
people like it right I like it uh on
that note I don't know let's go right
into it guys India and I continue to
want to bang out articles if you have
had success with any of the tactics from
the askgaryvee show here's your chance
to get totally humongous exposure
because we will write an article of like
four businesses that have benefited from
the askgaryvee show and india will
interview you she'll call you she's very
sweet so you'll give her advice you'll
give her advice excuse me you'll give
her the details and bam we'll blast it
out there more people more customers
more good stuff don't lie just to hack
to get in there truth I wanted I want
I'm a proof India because I'm a donation
can get a little shady Edward wants to
know what's the biggest way right now
you are hypocritical of your own advice
Edward this is a really really really
good question
this Edward this may be my favorite
question you know what Edward you've
also solved something else for me that
is tremendous which is people always ask
me what's that you know this Steve
what's the one question nobody ever asks
you that should ask you I think this is
really it Edward it's a moving target
right now luckily because I've built out
infrastructure a lot less right I'm
putting out content I'm doing a
consistent show and ek doing a ton of
Facebook dark posts we're doing a ton of
influencer stuff on Instagram I don't
think maybe a little bit we need a
little bit more oomph on Pinterest but
even that we're doing huh I would say
this in the historical track of me
giving advice since 2009 and business
this is easily the least hypocritical
least not following in my advice that
I've ever been in because I finally hit
scale where I can afford this incredibly
good-looking team show Steve what a
good-looking stuff
and so and so what do you guys think
actually this could be a lot of fun what
I'm trying to think of like what we're
not crushing on that we believe in so
much we're really doing well right now
go ahead it's okay you won't hurt my
feelings I think I think
jabbing online better I think well I
don't well by the way let come back to
me I Wine Library is like a daddy like
scam I think you know for sure
meanwhile Amber's got Instagram that can
be doing better pincher like in wine
Army's got its own spiel of reorganizing
can do better work Wine Library for sure
I'm talking about our world where I have
a little bit more control because I'm
not day-to-day Wine Library what do you
think is the thing India anything I
think SlideShare I'm a big right
SlideShare I think we've really that's
me and you like and and maybe I could be
giving a little bit more time and access
to Indian Steve for the follow-up
content I'm just like grinding so hard I
mean like there's just like not a minute
and the day I'm like we're literally
like talking on Sunday nights I mean
it's it's pretty intense 6:00 p.m. this
last Sunday so I don't know I don't know
I'm feeling really great right now about
it as good as I've ever felt Wine
Library as a whole could be doing better
definitely on Instagram there's so much
upside for wine business is there I can
be giving a little bit more access to
following up on content more episodes
we're grinding pretty good right now but
I but I want that question asked once a
quarter cuz I think it will matter hey
Gary
Tim Ferriss here Cheers top of the
morning to you and I have a question
because I look like Al Pacino after a
bender I am launching the Tim Ferriss
experiment and it is a hell of a thing
so how do you think television shows
will be launched two years from now both
in terms of distribution and in terms of
commercial that is my question because
there's gotta be many better ways
thank you Tim great to have you on the
show I know so many of the people in the
vaynernation or huge fans so that's a
lot of fun I'm sure a lot of you enjoy
that uh and and everybody in the
vaynernation should actually check out
Tim's Tim Ferriss experiment on iTunes
stuff on let's link that up in YouTube
and I'm sure it's easy to find for all
of us
on the podcast and on Facebook if you're
watching I'll maybe you can one of you
maybe jump in with like a quick comment
when this episode pops up on Facebook
and link to iTunes - first experiment to
me I think that um a couple things will
happen one I think there's gonna be a
crapload more over-the-top services
right so you've got Netflix but I think
you've got Vimeo starting to make some
noise I expect a lot of traditional
old-school digital leaders to get in
this game like Microsoft's gonna have to
be in this game yeah who's gonna have to
be in this game I think that the you
know snapchat is clearly a television
network I think Facebook in a lot of
ways goes that right I think everybody
that can own video is gonna try because
all the money's there
I think launching it will happen in the
way that you're doing it now right
you're asking this question in a micro
community where I'm now giving exposure
to it and so the days of going to the
Today Show or running commercials on a
big show or trying to get print or radio
like campaigns going there's now all
these fragmented societies and and
niches Facebook dark posts well you know
you know making infographics for
Pinterest getting a ton of Instagram
influencers having me on my show I'm
sure you're probably hitting the podcast
circuit tremendously hard you're
probably going to show up on 15 podcasts
over the next week or two which is
something you wouldn't have done 24
months ago and there'll be five to seven
other things that none of us know has
the attention of the consumer maybe an
app that comes out on the watch right
there's so much coming and so here's
what I can tell you I don't predict I
react but I do know this in 24 months
there'll be some new stuff stuff
i'ma said [ __ ] and then stuff [ __ ] and
stuff means stuff that's how it comes
out of my mouth question of the day was
a good question today ah I'm gonna go
very football on you what is your
favorite football team who do you want
your team to take one of you lucky
veiniacs will get an opportunity of me
buying a jersey of your favorite teams
actual pick if you predict it properly
in the comments section of YouTube
that's right and you know what and
Facebook so what's your favorite
football team and who do you want them
to select
if you're right you may get that
person's Jersey as a surprise by me you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
hey Chris Rock okay
you missed the holy [ __ ] yeah
[Music]